[Musique]
l'île de la réunion reste encore
aujourd'hui le théâtre d'une flambée de
violences urbaines
de nombreux services publics entreprises
et commerces sont bloqués ou
inaccessibles j'entends une message du
président ma république hier soir mais
la répression ne doit en aucune manière
être la seule réponse apportée par le
gouvernement
ces violences sont révélatrices d'une
crise bien plus profonde de la société
réunionnaise
il faut aujourd'hui plus que jamais
soutenir la société réunionnaise et
apporter des solutions urgentes et la
clé scientifique aux habitants des
territoires ultramarins
je le redis ici des actes intolérables
ont été commis et ils devront être puni
pour le maintien de l'ordre
des moyens considérables sont mobilisés
et j'en appelle au respect de nos
valeurs républicaines
les opération de déblocage sont en cours
elles vont se poursuivre avec fermeté
pour libérer les commerces et permettent
la circulation
au-delà de ces deux réponses et vous
avez raison qui est nécessaire est
immédiate
il faut entendre le malaise profond des
réunionnais
même si la situation n'est pas récente
je ne vais pas ici me dérober alors les
réunionnais ont peur pour leur avenir
ont peur pour leurs enfants souhaitent
effectivement que l'état les accompagne
avec l'ensemble des élus dans une
construction meilleur pour leur
territoire alors nous devons
collectivement leur apporter une réponse
nous avons pris nos responsabilités
proposer des actions concrètes dans le
livre bleu qui seront mis en action dès
mais notre mission à tous est de
permettre aux réunionnais de retrouver
confiance confiance en leurs territoires
confiance en leurs institutions
confiance en leur avenir
las de ne pas être écouté les élus ont
lancé un appel celui de marseille
restait quasiment sans réponse si ce
n'est un catalogue de bonnes intentions
pourtant il avait pris monsieur le
ministre au sérieux le président de la
république quand sûrement dans un moment
d'égarement
celui-ci leur déclarer il y a un an au
congrès des maires je m'engage à une
chose c'est venir chaque année rendre
des comptes des engagements que je viens
de prendre
sincèrement monsieur le ministre on
aurait imaginé mieux que ce renoncement
pour soutenir les mères lorsque l'on
sait que la majorité d'entre eux ne
souhaite plus investir après 2020 le
candidat en marche rêvé de changer le
personnel politique le président macron
pourrait malheureusement être comblé ma
question est donc simple alors que le
dialogue est au point mort sans que de
réelles avancées n'ai vu le jour
qu'envisagez vous concrètement pour
l'avenir de nos communes alors le
gouvernement comme l'a dit le premier
ministre comme l'a dit le président la
république et comme lady les ministres
concernés il laisse la porte ouverte
il souhaite que la conférence nationale
des territoires reste est soit le lieu
du dialogue entre les collectivités
locales
monsieur le sénateur jour et simplement
vous répondre vous avez raison il ya
besoin de dialoguer et je vais vous dire
c'est les associations d'élus le veulent
je crois que les maires des associations
comme l'association des maires de france
le demande
et je vais vous dire plus important
quand je crois que les citoyens le
veulent parce qu'il n'y aurait rien de
pire que l'autre et les collectivités
locales ne dialogue pas parce que nous
avons des sujets concrets à résoudre on
ne comprendrait qu'il n'y ait pas dit
alors je vous remercie
[Musique]